we don't like to hear those decorations
that's for sure and we know that we're
making changes all across southern
nevada with the desert landscaping and
certain mandates for those medians that
have to have the um the real grass
removed by a certain date too so and you
realize when you have a good rainstorm
turning off your sprinklers and your
drip systems just for a few days that
saves us thousands and thousands of
gallons of water when you have a good
rainstorm i try to remind everybody yeah
and overall just also like uh just
cutting back on on the water use when
you're when you're taking a shower when
you're brushing your teeth there's a
little bit that everyone can do yes yeah
hard to do when you're brushing your
teeth but i make it happen look at this
pretty blue you got on there ted i just
noticed that well you'll see it again
yes
but look at the morning temperatures i
want to pointed this out to you i was
going to show you on this this three
shot but 65 this morning okay
last time we had 65 in the morning was
june 10th it has been that long can you
believe that that felt so nice this
morning we said at 7 00 am a lot of
people walking their dogs going for that
morning jog and kirsten loves this
graphic so
let me show you again oh go up
okay so thursday 99 degrees ready you
guys ready to go
there we go that's what we dropped down
to she has the best sound effects for
this ah none for me 88 yesterday was
that great thursday 99 88 yesterday
normal is 93 this time of the year live
look outside right now from our camera
at red rock station casino i love this
shot because when we get good storms i
like looking off the mountain seeing
those storms start to pop up of course
it's dry outside 92 sky canyon right now
along with centennial hills these are
your current temps 91 north las vegas
same for sunrise manor so even though we
had cool morning temperatures temps warm
right back up to the 90s that's
typically what happens this time of year
80-70 mountains edge southern highlands
92 and anthem 89 degrees outside of town
86 for you in searchlight 93 for sandy
valley and 97 for lofla one spot still a
triple digits and of course it's the
hottest spot in the u.s death valley at
101 degrees at this hour so we're going
to heat up again for the first day of
fall the reason for that
high pressure i saw yesterday off the
coast now it's building back in
migrating back in the region look at
this jet stream amplified way up to
vancouver bc even the pacific northwest
is dry with this high in place numbers
are going to get close to 100 again
tomorrow and then we'll start to see
changes by the time we get to thursday
and beyond how about those winds though
yesterday those gusty winds today not so
bad we're going to keep those winds
rather tame for tomorrow too less than
10. it's a big weekend you heard ron
patrell okay nascar we've got the
raiders game on sunday we also have the
golden knights all right so how about
nascar that's outdoors right 96 saturday
97 sunday it's going to be hot but the
chances for showers are now backing off
with only very slight to slim chances on
sunday mainly east of las vegas so good
we want that track dry overnight lows
here is the the temperatures we're
expecting overnight we had a glorious
morning this time a little bit warmer
milder but still nice and comfortable
close to 70 high 60s across our
neighborhood centennial hills mountains
edge nellis henderson green valley close
to 70. regional temperatures outside of
town probably will be chilly at 58.70
for boulder city so tonight 71 cool and
clear we'll have a nice comfortable
start again 97 for tomorrow warmer for
the first day of fall
so we'll heat up
fall is at 12 21
midday
but we'll be hotter 97 degrees and then
the numbers drop again look at this mid
90s as we get through the week and into
your weekend along with mostly sunny
skies not bad at all that's your most
accurate forecast here on 8 news now